people may not think pizza coughing is a
serious sport it really is it's a lot of
hard work
[Music]
my name is Tony Gemignani and I'm a
12-time world pizza champion I have two
Guinness Book of World Records one for
most consecutive rolls across the
shoulders in 30 seconds
was 36 rolls across the shoulders 36 or
37 yeah we'll say 37 so keep the
acrobatic or tricks with pizza dough a
lot of people ask me you know pizza
throwing how do you describe it it kinda
like what a Harlem Globetrotter does
with a basketball but we do with the
pizza you know
around the back across the shoulders
through the leg two at a time on the
ground
spinning in your hands the difference
between you know a basketball on a pizza
it misshapes it gets bigger gets softer
not like it's juggling balls that are
always the same it's pretty magical so
every year in Las Vegas there's Pizza
Expo and that the pizza Expo there's the
world Pizza games when you walked it out
stage there's acrobats from all around
the world competing they'll be getting
judged by a panel of three to five
judges and those judges will look for
dexterity creativity difficulty and as
they're judging them they'll look for
drops and they'll look for transitions
from trick to trick there's about a two
to three minute routine of music they
have to nail it they've been practicing
all year for it there's a trick in the
sport called the Gemignani in my last
name it's a trick that I did it's two
across your shoulders and you catch it
nobody loves even more than me you know
even I have on my chest and pizza for
life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]